[Music]
in I'm done news out of hair
submitted by SIPP is mother amazing do
yourself a favor but it's only in
Westwood right
I haven't also Smorgasburg Smorgasburg
every sunday sunday sunday sunday sunday
downtown LA this is gonna be the 66
night market it's gonna be at the six
two six nine mortgage cool
listen geez I heard you Gio I liked it a
104 year-old man decides to end his life
with the help of assisted suicide Oh
congratulations
a common thing though he was gonna die
in like a week anyways true I mean if
you're a hundred four is it really
assisted suicide I think that's just
life and he was probably going through
so much like medical [ __ ] like oh so
he's like [ __ ] I've been trying to die
the last fourteen years right yo mother
a hundred and four damn that's [ __ ] oh
that's fun it's kind of crazy though cuz
my brother here a nurse and he's saying
that he has a certain pace patients that
are going through like severe cancer you
know towards like the last stages and
you'll see them just they'll say it out
live just let me die it's so painful so
painful they don't want to go through it
that's just heartbreaking net yeah it's
a real [ __ ] though my um my dad my dad's
always he's joking but he's always like
you know I just need four more years
then I'm good he's like he's like 16 oh
my god yeah he's like four more years
that's it that's what I tell him I'm
like dad look if you want to keep
pressuring me to crank up these babies
with Chia you better stick around you
know I'm saying I was like I'm not about
to give them a cool ass grandpa for a
couple years and then for you to just
die alright and then it he feels like
he's like oh you're making me feel bad
you don't like that shut up you know
what my dad tells me he's like man I
want to see Tycho's grandkids I don't
like you know that's not possible right
and he goes why would you say something
like that oh my you're not gonna live
[ __ ] 200 years
crazy ass [ __ ] your dad is so
unreasonable dude how it is hot like
sixty five or six 7000 sixty he can't do
it
Tigers grandkids know if tiger wall
Tigers part Mexican
so yeah he might get starting early so
was I we're not harmful ways yeah but we
had this one I hear yeah but she's not
much Wow okay let's see person if 18 if
he was 18 and he pops one out a kid
Tigers grandkids goodies have a son
Oh tigers grand key yeah that's what he
said yes oh I thought he meant like
Tigers kids the audacity of your father
you angry at you or say something so
stupid could you see such a thing my kid
yeah that's what you said that's ones
some are you [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
yeah swim zoos I think my brain just
couldn't even like that's why I was just
thinking those Tigers kid yeah yes David
here they were talking about 104 years
he's an Australian scientist who is
flight to Switzerland to silence women
damn whoa all because they do the
assisted suicides over there yes so in
Australia it's currently not legal to do
assisted suicide but in 2019 there's one
state that it will become legal for
terminally ill patients but he doesn't
he's 140 still [ __ ] trucking man
there's a whole head of hair - yes man
oh you see his shirt go back insurance
as aging disgracefully
[Laughter]
I'm happy he's like I'm not happy I just
want to die already like someone buy him
that [ __ ] ratted on him so he's saying
like hopefully by him wanting to die
especially at this age he wants to bring
like awareness like older people like
you know they don't all want to live
forever
right like people yeah you should let
people decide when you know I've had
enough of my life that's true and he's
also he's not like the hundred and four
like Japanese lady who was a completely
functioning still gardening cleaning the
house you know I mean he looks pretty
liked ability I think my dad would do
the same thing because like he he is the
type of guy to be like I don't want to
be like you know with tubes all over me
like I don't want it like you know
taking like pills and in pain all the
time he would be like you know I lived a
long life let me go is your dad like
unhealthy right now he's alright he's
alright for sixty six year olds you have
otherwise tripping so much man I mean he
has some complications but you know it's
just how he is you know he's just kind
of like you know what I don't want to
like worry about all that he's like if
when it's my time it's my time I said
you know I mean my dad didn't talking
about death ever since all the little
kids oh dude that's a all Asian patch
yeah mommy gonna die soon I'm too let me
let me there but we talked about in a
funny way like my dad always says like
when when he dies he wants me to UM to
get him stuffed and put a set up in my
living room with it with a hand up so
people can high-five him when he comes
last I told me to take her ashes and
scatter it across the ocean I told I'm a
flush in the toilet you bastard so
you're not gonna know you're dead
anyways how do you say you bastard in
Korean it's like chaos IQ or whatever
he's up with kinda like you not do them
as a you bad person
oh yeah yeah so David he's just saying
that you know you should let people
decide when do you want to just I think
so I mean people should be in charge of
their own lives yeah cuz I live right
now in the u.s. assisted suicide is
legal in Oregon Vermont Washington
California Colorado
Hawaii and Washington DC I would get
assisted suicide in Hawaii that's pretty
nice place to go you know I'm the ocean
I mean if out you might change your mind
if you get there though right
no but check this out if I if I really
wanted to die and I knew I wanted to die
be like yo [ __ ] the hospital take me up
in a plane drop me off I'm a fly into
the ocean you know like just let me fly
for like you wanna drown I mean there I
mean not feel like if I jumped out of a
plane I'd be dead by the time I hit the
Y but the impact super lucky I have
really good luck so I probably would
survive and just be like Pistons around
like somehow you flew off right and then
you let it to somebody else's parachute
oh my and then you stole their
parachutes I just look down but you live
oh yeah what's that I can't catch a
break because they're saying that the
laws in Switzerland it's required for
the patient to administer the drug and
sort like to turn the the knob
themselves oh and they will first fall
asleep and then within a few minutes
alright within a half an hour they
that's one death Oh half hour not bad
it's painless you know just put on like
an episode of The Fresh Prince and just
yeah crazy no you'll fall asleep within
a few minutes and then half an hour
after you fall asleep what if you regret
it would it feel like this right there
like turn it back there's a nurse come
go no don't be a little [ __ ] myself no
that's crazy
and they're also required to film it
because that's how that's like the only
way you can really prove that the
patient right so no one came like accuse
you of like murderers so you got to do a
selfie of that what a weird business
what up guys my last post what's up
what's up low gang he's like this is
kind of ironic the whole suicide forest
okay yeah yeah he's just saying like he
doesn't he's losing his mobility
he can't be right he's like there's no
way don't it sounds like me it does not
my use I was like my everyday life yeah
Keita yeah happy trying though
I got us this deal with the rear naked
choke no I used in a front front fully
clothed choke on me that's it was not
nice formal snap my neck and half does a
reverse really I think I'd [ __ ] end
up growing cucumbers or something if I'm
with geezer just farmer so yeah like I
got a do something man I got to do
something that's like outdoors
physically active but what if that's it
you you don't have mobility like that
guy you're in a wheelchair well
hopefully technology is good enough to
where I could play like Sims in my head
and they could hook me up and I do and
it's like a black mirror
yes and repair oh but that's after you
die or like Vanilla Sky is who y'all
have Siva no this guy the same [ __ ] he
was like he had a horrible accident and
he was in like a simulation for a long
last time he didn't even realize it
yeah and then it started glitching
that's how it Q to me yeah I'll be cool
with that
yeah if you could just take my
consciousness to another world was that
cool
really I'd rather just die really see
what happens on the other side I really
just be like yeah true why that's cool
too it depends if life sucks
if life doesn't suck I'd keep it to be
honest with you of my life like
completely sucked right now I just I
just take me to the other world [ __ ] it
dude I'll just be doping that of the
world no but then you have so much more
like I mean if life suck now you saw so
much more life though it could change
make it better yeah because there's so
many stories of them like or like viral
just viral shits that I've read from
people who are like you know what when I
was however old I was suicidal but then
I stuck with it and now I'm like the
mother of like three beautiful children
I'm like so glad I didn't do it you know
my life is beautiful now and now I
wished I would have done it cuz my three
kids are crazy me crazy
yeah suicide sucks for him how do you
know you never did it bro
I've been trying to every day son it's
don't see
you have not kidding I've never had
suicidal thoughts for some reason yeah I
mean even not that's it that's a lot of
people do though like I've never had
that yeah I thought that was normal
junior high high school now I never have
that [ __ ] oh yeah I think I think it's
more I mean as normal as like I didn't a
lot of people realize how common it is
to be like depressed and to have like
super like you know anxiety and all that
stuff and I didn't realize how common it
was until you know until the kind of
rise of the Internet and so many people
talking about it like I thought it was
you know weird if someone was depressed
but like the more you kind of hear
people's stories and how serious it is
and then it's kind of like oh wow this
is really kind of common for someone to
have suicidal thoughts or be depressed
like like I thought it was normal cause
everybody did it did drugs and whatever
around me I never had like suicidal
thoughts but then like I know I never
called the depression that was just like
me I'm just really [ __ ] out of a rut
people don't even know I think people
misuse the word they don't even know
where they're at so I think meme I'm
just in a rut yeah I mean I don't never
call I don't think I don't know what
depression really is because maybe I've
never felt that I just feel like I can't
get out of it you don't mean I thought
no I can't get out of this it's just
right now which it's not happening yeah
yeah I think everyone goes through the
depression it depends on how long you
stay exactly you know I was always happy
to [ __ ] man as a happy kid bro I'm done
you man I said weird self esteem is just
too high for no [ __ ] reason dude it's
so so noise that I've had sometimes I
just want to change for the better but
that I'm just like dude you're perfect
man
why give yourself a pep talk for no
reason is [ __ ] I was like 30 pounds
heavier just two and a half months ago
and even then I'm like - you look great
I mean that's good though you do look
great but what got me was just the you
can't you can't fake being tired
exhausted you know that type of [ __ ]
that's all your joints know your joints
hurting you know all that other [ __ ] but
you could tell yourself that you feel
fine or you're healthy as much as you
want your body will let you know that
you feel like [ __ ] yeah been a while
like you lose that delusion and then
it's like okay when I [ __ ] run to go
get the mail I don't want to go back
upstairs
there's a problem here you know hey look
good man
thank you sir how funny any more of it
[ __ ]
[Music]